[Musique]
dit que la réalité n'est pas fictive
nous pourrions aussi exposer des coupures sanglantes
brûlures ébouillante personnes défigurées
avec de l'acide
mais nous ne voulions pas faire cela nous ne voulions pas
une éclaboussure quelque chose que nous ne voulions pas
montrer l'horreur
la beauté des dalles et nous sommes tous
nos os sont essentiellement les mêmes
sont tous pareils donc chacun de
ceux-ci peuvent être n'importe quelle femme et
ils sont là depuis le début de l'année
donc dès le premier janvier 320 femmes
Je ne parle que des femmes qui sont
émeutes aux urgences déclarant
une dynamique violente alors ils sont de
regarder de plus près ces données
parce que j'ai regardé le nombre pur e
brut peut être des femmes qui sont
revenir quelques fois puis le
la même femme qui y est retournée deux fois
ceci par exemple un index de
danger incroyable
[Musique]